[creator] okay and we're back so all the agents just finished the build agents at least
[creator] so they're all done it's still so annoying with how glitchy it is there
[creator] and I just asked orbit what's next it says all four builds are are finished
[creator] each one reviews cleanly yada yada yada
[creator] Um, next you need to merge all four branches into main.
[creator] Each task word tree is separate, yada, yada.
[creator] So I'll go ahead and get these merged.
[creator] Confirm it to you before any that we're facing.
[creator] So just pushing, go ahead and push these, um, or actually just go
[creator] ahead and merge this, I'm just going to tell each one of these to merge.
[creator] Go ahead and merge this to main
[creator] to main not me
[creator] Merge this to main and tell this one as well. Go ahead and merge this to main
[creator] I've went ahead and had each one of them merge of
[creator] When I had and had
[creator] It understands what I'm saying. It's alright. So now
[creator] it is creating a
[creator] a new agent to integrate and play test.
[creator] Create a new canvas called integrate.
[creator] Integrate, I said integrate.
[creator] Gotta wait for that, okay.
[creator] I'll let this finish.
[creator] Actually, we'll call it play test.
[creator] When this finishes, we will move it over to play test.
[creator] So I will be back when that is done.